so let's be clear launch screens are all
the rage nowadays with material design
but you have to make sure that you do it
in the right way my name is Colt McAnlis
and doing launch screens properly
results in a great branded experience
but the wrong way could hurt the user
perception of performance remember when
the user launches your app they'll be
shown a launch screen while your app is
loading and getting ready to display if
your application launch is pretty quick
then this preview window is only
displayed for a quick flash and then
your app will appear however if you have
a slow loading experience this image can
hang around on screen for quite some
time causing users to either exit out or
you can get the dreaded application not
responding dialog now some developers in
order to hide this slow launch
experience decide to theme their apps
launch screen so that it's thematically
consistent with the rest of the app
rather than looking like the system
theme start window let's be clear while
this seems like it solves the problem it
doesn't see in this scenario the screen
may look better but that doesn't make it
immune to users exiting due to slow load
times or the a in our dialog popping up
basically you're just covering up the
problem another way to cover this up is
to turn off the initial startup window
using the window disable preview
attribute when you do this rather than
the launch screen being displayed
nothing's shown so the home screen
sticks around until your app suddenly
pops up this feels like a different
problem to the user basically what
appears to be the screen freezing or
stop responding to input and then so
then just jam the finger at it listen
user perception of your launch time is
really important and not something you
want to mess up so if you're going to
put in some launch screen branding make
sure to do it the right way first you
should address your load time issues of
your application now things like long
view inflation lots of object
instantiation or too many resources
being loaded are common things which can
be fixed to allow a faster experience
for your users check out the videos
we've done on those topics now when
that's done and only when that's done
you can think about your loading screens
and if you're going to do it do it the
right way rather than disabling the
preview window it's recommended to
follow the common material design
patterns and provide a simple custom
draw before the starting activity this
your app to display your custom drawable
as a start up window rather than the
default one however once it's time for
the app to load you need to set your
activity theme to the real theme you
want inside of your oncreate method the
result is a nice branding experience
coupled with quick load times resulting
in happier users and that's really what
performance is all about right I mean
faster apps leading to happier users
that's why you should check out the rest
of the Android performance patterns
content and don't forget to join our
Google+ community for other great tips
and tricks so keep calm profile your
code and always remember perf matters